we turn now our attention back to White
House Press Secretary future NBC
employee and star Jen saki who no longer
seems too interested in actually
answering any questions she doesn't even
Circle back anymore how disappointing
today she ducked a question about the
disinformation board she avoids
questions about the Border crisis and it
is a crisis and of course she refuses to
answer questions about Joe Biden's ties
to his son's Shady business deals we're
also learning tonight that Hunter Biden
and his business associate they visited
the Obama Biden White House seven times
after becoming head of the company with
had a company with ties to the Communist
Chinese party wow but don't expect Jen
sake to field any questions about that
in fact many reporters now reportedly I
guess are afraid to ask sake tough
questions because she's a bully Who
quote makes you look like a a-hole hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe live to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else